Pues los informes de gendarmería que
fueron difundidos por un medio
informaban de que seis de estas personas
indultadas Tenían un riesgo alto o muy
alto de volver a reincidir y que tenían
poca conciencia de los delitos cometidos
y por eso advertían en contra de esos
indultos el tema vuelve sobre la mesa al
gobierno de Gabriel borich que ha
evitado referirse a él fue cuestionado
el viernes y dijo que toda la
información está ahora en el tribunal
constitucional es la misma línea se
manifestó el ministro de Justicia Luis
Cordero que dijo que no se puede referir
a estos antecedentes puesto que están
por el en el tribunal constitucional que
está viendo como pidió la oposición si
estos indultos pueden declararse o no
inconstitucionales Además la polémica
sea viva porque también Se confirmó un
nuevo indulto en trámite la oposición
Pide a la cámara de diputados que active
la comisión de investigación sin
delación puesto que ya lleva unos meses
desde que se solicitó y que investiguen
si estos esta medida podría llevar o no
en algunos casos algunos de ellos
especialmente de sectores como
renovación nacional hablan también de la
posibilidad de presentar una demanda de
inconstitucionalidad una demanda de
constitucionalidad también contra el
presidente